back to the uh the china question no
well so
uh i i we had china censored on the show
i asked him about this and i'm wondering
are you familiar with thucydides trap uh
yeah vaguely
basically like we're facing a potential
war with china based on historical
precedent
i'm wondering if we're already actually
we're already in it you know a lot of
people might want might not want to
acknowledge this but cyber war between
us and china has been pretty intense for
a long time
let me just draw back to that word
political war right political warfare
has been happening
um the the biggest sign that i ever saw
with that was the chinese have a term to
make fun of the woke which is
by yes yeah it means it means white left
and white left it does yeah and then all
of a sudden like the the wumao accounts
on twitter or
yeah twitter stopped making fun of them
it's like all of a sudden it was like
it's not making fun of them and then the
accounts were like
america has a big systemic racism
problem yeah yep and it's like all of a
sudden they realize that this is a
weapon
um because they used to make fun of the
white left yeah well now it's now they
can see that it's destroying the country
and they should embolden it was mao's
revolution a form of political war in
the beginning
uh i mean yeah they were engaging in
political warfare for sure
the the goal with the cultural
revolution was kind of to cover up for
the failure of the great great leap
forward so that mao could reclaim power
so the great leap forward was when he
took all the farmers out of the farm
yeah and he took all the farmers and
said you guys are gonna all make steel
because steel is the one big measurement
yeah and they all ended up making crappy
pig iron and
nobody was growing food yeah and so
command economy baby
it was like the great leap into the
dumpster is what it worked out to be
a great leap into 50 million dead people
pretty much okay that's not funny
not so funny but um yeah so that was a
huge failure and they actually kind of
chased mal out of power
and i'm not real sharp on the the
chinese history with remembering who all
the names are in the gang of four and
all of this stuff
but then mao came back with uh basically
with his little red book indoctrinating
students and young people in
universities and schools
and uh unleashed what he called the red
guard in the cultural revolution to
destroy the four olds of society
and you know old habits old ideas old
customs old ways of thinking
what do you think is happening right now
it's like you know dr
seuss was a man of his time we have to
destroy that his time was terrible
um thomas jefferson was a man of his
time throw a statue in the lake
abraham lincoln man of his time take the
name off the school in
san francisco throw his statue in the
lake too you know right
right like the antifa a or whatever it
is on on his face with spray paint
uh yeah anarchy that's which apparently
they don't understand what that means
no i love this people claiming to be
yeah right yeah exactly that's a better
one yeah
authoritarianism by the way in that
essay just to
not to dive into this but sn liberation
i was reading uh you repeatedly have
marcus refl
refer to the the need to raise the the
flag the red and the black flag that's
what he's always referring to throughout
that
in case you wonder like who he's
connected to yeah what's that the
fascist and the communist flag
no no red and black is uh left anarchy
it's a symbol of what is it black is
labor
yes and red is red
yeah it's socialism and anarchy is what
it is yeah yeah um
and then there's black and yellow that's
why luke luke really likes black and
yellow but
that's capitalism that's that fan yeah
right that's the fancy symbol of of
antifa
has a black and a red flag that's that's
what it is yeah and so
he's referring to that in 1969 it's like
empowering the black and the red the
even says the black and the red flag
must be empowered behind this
and it's like huh now anti-fascist
acton or however it said in german my
german pronunciation is not very good
you know what the berlin wall's real
name was
no the anti-fascist protection rampart
that was the actual name of the berlin
wall
which is called the berlin wall because
that's the colloquial name that's the
common name
but i think it's important we remember
what the true name was yeah exactly i
mean this is the thing so i was reading
bella dodd's testimony
again i read it in december or november
last year and i was reading it again a
little bit today and a little bit last
week
and um bela dad was a member of the
communist party usa
who confessed and or she actually left
the party defected
and in 1953 she confessed everything
basically about the communist party's
ideas to the house committee on american
activities now known as the house
judiciary committee
and uh well not quite it assumed all of
that former committee's roles and duties
which are technically not dissolved but
um she's confessing and she says you
will always find i put this on twitter
just yesterday
or the day before you'll always find
that the communist plan is to dress up
its activities in high
high-minded terms so you'll find the
communists saying that we're the
anti-fascists
right and so if you oppose communism you
must be pro-fascist
and that was a she was saying this in
the 1950s about how
i met what happened i'm an
anti-republican i mean good i mean i
have those memes about becoming an
anti-republican yeah yeah see i'm an
anti-republican
that and that means i believe in free
speech it means i believe in you know
the right of the individual to assemble
the constitution and if you oppose me
you're pro-republican yeah that's the
problem yeah yeah exactly
i'm glad you understand the logic the
communists would say um rightists
they hunted down the righteous they did
righteous and ten righteous beliefs this
was big with mao
also of course bourgeois but um but they
did go right after rightist it's too
naked
but i mean marcusa put that his essay
regressive tolerance from 1965
the thesis statement like is literally
almost word for word
movements from the left must be
tolerated under all circumstances
movements from the right must not be
tolerated
what terrifies me is when i find myself
saying people
on the left i feel like i've been
indoctrinated
and am subconsciously being used as a
pawn
to segregate this culture war no that's
true what needs to be done is that the
the willful actors who are participating
in this need their own
identifiable name that actually sticks
woke is a thing
but it's slangy right um critical social
justice is the term that shows up in
their
literature but it's scholarly you know
we can get really technical
it's a critical constructivist that's
what they're fighting mongooses that's a
good team name yeah i know right yeah
that's not too bad flying eagles um but
i
i don't know you know what exactly to
call them the repressive left would work
but people have tried variations it was
regressive left for a long time
repressive is actually more
that's called my editarians
identitarians is good yeah
the identity marxists fits i think an
editarian works because
uh it's the core ideology for a lot of
what they what they push
and google search what identitarian
means and then you know
yeah authoritarian i like a lot too if
you think about it but it's identitarian
these are people who want
they want law based on race yeah they
want law and policy based on identity
that's better because if we think of it
as left
then they'll use that right and hunt
people down right
and it's easy to be be opposed to racism
in all its forms right yeah racism is
wrong in all its forms is a very
powerful
uh simple statement that also has the
concept of
robert lifton what are called
thought-stopping technique which
is what they use on you all the time
when they call you a racist they're
using thought-stopping techniques
right lyfton was by the way describing
how mao was able to
use the red guard to take over uh when
he talked about cult
cults being built uh he's specifically
analyzing the maoist one
they're gonna put half a million dollars
into this autonomous zone apparently
i don't know what that means did they
say what it was for or no it's gfas
yeah that's cool i'm not going to lie
stepping out of the system for a minute
gfas sounds cool
but you want to go down and hang out at
the g fest i don't know yes
shoot me so i'm not going oh never mind
yeah journalists showed up and they were
like something bad's about to happen
right now he's like i'm okay we're
leaving yeah that's true what a loser
yeah if this journalist shows up he's
like what do you mean i'm outside and
they're like you better leave i'd be
like shut your mouth kid go home
again make it happen that's a decision
dilemma too
there you go put in a decision dilemma
yep and they people are cowards
wait what do you mean what's the
decision to limit you you have to either
show weakness or you have to overreact
interesting when they get up in your
face and they're like you better get out
of here
well i was actually talking about the uh
just the establishment of an autonomous
zone at all
they're right they're they're basically
playing chicken with the city and if the
city overreacts they're going to be like
help fascists
this is why we need clown block clown
block
yeah is that like bat anti-shark spray
100 people dressing clowns
just dancing and playing music and like
banging drums and like
you know because there's there's no
aggression there's no attack there's no
affiliation
it's it's bizarre and it occupies space
and
sullies their ideology that's very
butlerian
listen if you send in a group of proud
boys it's
horrifying white supremacists attacking
poor black lives matter protesters so my
friend told me that the proud boy should
all put on
like they should march socially
distanced on purpose they should all
wear rainbow masks
they should have like you know like the
the the feminist power fist
like in the circle with the plus on
their like emblazoned on their chest or
whatever
they should go in singing like john
lennon's imagine and then just see what
happens because that puts them in the
position dilemma
but sure but the story would then be uh
far-right white supremacists troll
black people maybe what happens if a
bunch of
unnamed unidentifiable clowns show up
playing music and banging drums and
giving out funnel cake and cotton candy
400 articles about the joker they'll
just say a bunch of clowns showed up and
are occupying the space and playing
music
and when when they're asked about what
they're doing they just go
and then who are the clowns the people
that occupy the autonomous zone of
course
exactly yeah they're all clowns yeah
john mason is just occupied by a large
group of clowns
that's it each and every clown is
unidentifiable
they're not a political faction they
have no political ideology their their
faces are painted and they're wearing
wigs they're not identifiable they don't
bring weapons they don't fight anybody
literally just clowns having fun riding
little tricycles and laughing and
hugging and dancing
and what would happen if a parade of
clowns with balloons got brutally beaten
by
antifa it would be art that was watched
for millennia
people would reference those videos of
the clowns being taken away in handcuffs
by who
by like in movies it would be terrifying
it's a decision
what can these groups do if clowns
occupy their space
peaceful happy go lucky friendly
family-friendly people
there just to have us bring a smile to
people's faces who may be sad this is
this is you are creating the decision
dilemma back for them right
now look at actually what you have to do
no public announcements no organization
just a hundred clowns showing up on a
certain date
just to bring joy to people joy and
peace and love and
uh funnel cake of course anti-violence
and if you if you oppose the
anti-violence then you're pro-violence
that's right you'd have to sustain it to
really have an impact like
seven to seven weeks of clowns and they
could always be the same clowns but
different people
but you could do this everywhere you
could do it everywhere
because when you look at the black block
what the activists do and they all wear
black you can't figure out who these
people are
you don't necessarily know what their
ideology is or they want and it's they
do this on purpose so they can't get
caught when they commit crimes yeah
exactly
how are you going to smear a bunch of
clowns just a bunch of crochet dude i'm
in it no this is good
this is this i mean it creates the
necessary dynamic that
you have to do people ask me all the
time like what's basically the strategy
what kind of things you have to do
you have to put that they're trying to
put you in a decision dilemma you have
to put them back in the decision dilemma
and mid-level violence
you know what happens how you do it one
of these leftists are just like a clown
and throw a molotov
oh oh yeah that's true that's the other
thing because like i was talking to a
guy who wants a
like i can't build technologies and
maybe you guys can he was saying that
would be really helpful is if you have
like this app where even if it's just
anonymous that you know
you know you could type in your school
board or whatever like brown school
board or whatever
and you could find a school district and
you could find out like parents can go
in and opt in
anonymously or whatever maybe there's a
community function maybe there's not but
you could actually just know
there's like 90 other parents in the
school's school district who oppose
critical race theory
so you feel more emboldened to be able
to speak up and if you could connect
with one another
even if it's anonymous at first or
whatever but i was like that's just
gonna get
like activists are just gonna make fake
accounts and descend on that
like crazy right um maybe if it's like
you know just the
yes there are people here you can make
it anonymous like you know
yeah no one can see your name so you can
say whatever you want right i mean
that would have to be the case because
the second they find out who you are you
know
there's trouble i don't think so i think
the only reason there's trouble is
because there's a hundred people
10 of them are pointing you know the
baseball bat
and the other 90 are like but no will
have my back yeah well this is
the the odds aren't that good for them
actually the
i've heard so many stories now because i
get like preferential stories of this
sort sent to me
i've heard so many stories where you
have a school district for example that
serves maybe
five ten thousand families total in a
community
and the people do some digging and find
out that it's a dozen activists
12 against thousands right and i've had
cases in
where there's been small cities in the
u.s where
people on either like the city council
or whatever have contacted me and said
you know we did some digging you know
we're getting constant relentless
harassment and tons of
comments on all the message boards but
we bought from different accounts well
they're all fake
turns out there's like 20 people only
one of them is a constituent because you
have to have one to be able to file
stuff and it's like
what tipped them off is like why does
the same person file everything
right you know that requires a
constituent to file but it's like it's
the only one
it looks like there's 400 people this
happens to me on twitter all the time
so i tweet something about hegel's
philosophy like anybody cares right
and uh all of a sudden you know i could
start getting dunked on which is
strange enough it must be touching some
wire and then
i'm having like cartoon characters with
like 60 followers reply tweet to my
tweet
getting 300 400 likes within an hour or
two
like you can't tell me that's organic
like that's not normal
i that's that's not normal twitter
behavior in any universe so you just
don't check notifications well no the
point is
that what you actually have with a lot
of these activists is you have a
perception
that there are lots of them but what
there actually are very small numbers of
them
usually with lots of accounts that are
are swarming
in artificial fake ways to make it look
like there's lots and lots and lots of
people that's a military tactic where
you'll you'll make it seem like there's
more of you
surrounding the enemy to confuse them
set off explosives over there and noise
over there
yeah yeah i think these people feel like
they're insurgents they are
insurgents they know their insurgents
the ones who are not just like your
average
like dopey foot soldier woki they know
what they're doing they're very informed
they know that they're just trying to
claim power they know what the tactics
are they have books like
good or like beautiful trouble that are
active as handbooks that tell them how
to do this
i'm in a bit of a loss maybe you can
help now i'm a big advocate of turn the
other cheek
i i believe if someone wrongs you you
the best thing you can do is just allow
it understand see their humanity but i
also see they crucified jesus
after he told people to do that so like
one time a friend of mine would smack my
leg a lot and i was like ah it really
hurt and i was like
stop please stop hitting me but she she
just was doing it was just programmed to
do it and one day i said if you do it
again i'm going to hit you as hard as
you're hitting me
so she did it again and i hit her
smacked her super hard
and she was screamed out and never hit
me again no
the situation was solved yeah you hear
this with parents and
children who bite a lot is that they
finally just you know bite the
the kid back and it's like that's what
it feels like they can't ever bite
the kid never bites again and it's like
um
there is a point there uh and this is
where i was saying earlier you know
cancel that if someone comes to cancel
you cancel them first
it's kind of like a it's semi-humorous
you know
thing but um i don't think until i keep
saying the symmetry the asymmetry is the
story the asymmetry is the goal the goal
of repressive tolerance from 1965
was to create this asymmetry left good
right bad
uh marcus in that essay by the way if
you want to see how touch how close to
what's
happening now it is he says that the
problem isn't even that right-wing
movements exist and do things and
whether they would be violent they have
to be stopped at the point where the
thought enters their head
therefore it requires not even just
censorship but pre-censorship of
movements from the right
and that asymmetry is what's being
attempted that's what cancer culture is
meant to do
cancer culture is meant to create
pre-censorship in other words
the idea is not even out there anymore
people are afraid even if they hold the
idea to say it because if they say
they're going to get canceled they're
going to get shot down off of their
platform they're going to lose whatever
it is that's their living or whatever
happens to be
the kids are going to get harassed at
school so pre-censorship to prevent
people from even
feeling like they can say the thing is
really their objective
until the symmetry is restored it's just
going to be l after l
after l after l stacking up until people
grow spines
and just say shut up i don't care well i
mean historically speaking from what
i've been told but i'm not a scholar of
this i can't talk about it deeply is is
until the
children of the actual elites start
having an impact
the parents i should say of the children
have see it impacting their children's
lives but
they're they're it's already happening
sort of they're playing into it
sort of i mean that's the problem is a
lot of people at that level
have bought into the ideology yeah i
hear from parents all the time that say
like the one thing i wish more
desperately than any is that i could
talk to other parents in my kids school
and say don't you just think this is all
bogus don't you think it's a terrible
idea that they're bringing in trans
strippers to dance those people
need to have someone throw a large
ice cold water balloon in their face
well they said what's happening is they
know that if especially and this is true
in private schools elite private schools
that if they say that to the wrong
parent their kids going to get pushed
out of good
why is your kid in that school in the
first place that's kind of
that's kind of the feeling that i have
i've been kind of pissed off at people
for a long time which
it's like you know people are like i'm
scared i'm going to lose my job it's
like everybody's going to lose their job
if this goes badly why do you want to
work for a company that's funding this
yeah you know look the i i've stopped
caring a lot about these autonomous
zones to a certain degree
in that portland voted for the writers
they literally voted for the rioters
and a lot of people are like dude i
can't leave i'm stuck i sympathize i
empathize if you're stuck and you can't
afford to leave i understand
but maybe at a certain point to realize
that we live in trying times and the
world is not perfect
see for me maybe it's easier i don't
have i don't i don't have children
i've been homeless before i'm not scared
of it if i had to just
walk into the woods i bet okay but too
many people are scared they lived in
comfort for too long and they're scared
of losing that luxury because they don't
understand what it's like
to actually have to survive on the
streets and you know what surviving on
the streets infinitely easier than
surviving in the woods
and you don't even have to do that no
one's talking about you know making you
a homeless person living under a bridge
we're just saying they might take your
kid out of the school and then you got
to figure out something for your kid
yeah homeschool them that this is this
is the truth is that
the thing that you said that we live in
trying times now and people have to
start living as though
i mean this is something i get mad about
the the very smart people a lot is
you know my opinion is i would agree
with you if the world was the same way
it was five years ago
i think even said that i got asked a
question i gave a talk recently at a
major university a very famous major
university
and um i got asked a question that was
very much to that you know they were
like well don't you think you turn
people off by some of the way that you
behave on twitter and the way that you
behave
and i was like um first of all i don't
care
at all good bye but second of all
most importantly is like i can't first
why buy because i can't put a chain
around my neck and constrain the way
that i need to feel like i need to talk
to say what i need to say because it
might upset somebody who follows me
on twitter i don't care but secondly and
much more importantly
if the world was the way it was five
years ago i would
or the way we thought it was five years
ago i probably would believe
believe you or agree with you but it's
not
we're in a bad situation right now and
if you don't act like we're in a bad
situation right now
and start living like what time it
actually is
then this just keeps getting worse and
it gets harder i told people this at the
beginning of the riots last summer this
won't blow over
the longer you wait to stand up the
harder it gets i'll put it this way
you're on it we're all in a boat
and that boat is taking on water and
you've got people like me
and james lindsey and ian and other
people we have on the show who are
looking you in the face right now and
say
start bailing and they're going but you
know
i don't i don't know if i should because
like i mean you know then people are
gonna get they're gonna
find out that i know the ship is sinking
and then i'd rather look if i climb to
the top of the titanic and go to the
back
it's not sinking over that's actually
going up i think that'll be fine it's
like bro
the whole thing's going to split in half
and it's going to go under and i'll tell
you this
we're all making our ways toward the
lifeboats
we tried bailing water maybe we're past
that point now we're at the point where
those of us who've been paying attention
and many of you who are watching
have already started getting ready for
whatever those lifeboats figuratively
are
and a lot of people who think they can
sit back and shut up and keep their head
down
are going to be in for a very very rude
awakening i will tell you once there's a
meme
where death goes knocking on every door
and every door has
like a trail of blood coming out and the
meme will show like video game companies
or movies or whatever
and then he's knocking on the next door
people seem to think
i will sit in my house and as these
psychopaths go door-to-door threatening
people
if i put up the flag they'll walk past
me and then oh no one day they don't
they knock on your door and they say
well you're gonna give us money now
like they did to the businesses in in
louisville you know that story yeah
they went the black lives matter went
around to all the local businesses
downtown and said
tithe or else and when one cuban
immigrant said no
they shattered a pot and said tithe or
else and then they set up barricades and
called him racist
and shut down his business that's what
happens tithe or else
they demanded a percentage of the income
from these businesses
sit back at your own peril fine but
don't come crawling to me
when you keep saying but i'm scared to
talk to the other parents
okay well then you reap what you've sown
you are the one
watering the flowers of destruction and
then you're gonna come and complain
about it later
dude the rest of us are getting into the
weeds and pulling out the trash and
getting rid of the grubs
while you're sitting back saying i don't
want to get my hands dirty okay i'll say
yes bail pick up a pail and bale the
water
love it also get the lifeboats ready but
i think we can salvage the hull so if
you're interested in the structure
of the system and you want to repair it
that is also possible but we need to get
the lifeboats ready and we need to bail
that is by speaking your mind online you
make a video
you let people know it's by talking to
other parents
and saying that's ridiculous no i'm
sorry that makes no sense
and then if they get mad and they huff
and puff be like you mermaid you keep
you're cool
and you be polite and you be nice and
you let them freak out
you want them to show their true colors
when they have the tribalist panic
attack
that's right and this is why i always
try to be very nice
on on twitter because i want people to
look at the interactions between these
lunatics and see someone saying
i'm sorry i didn't mean to upset you and
them saying f you you slimeball i hate
your guts
and then when a regular person who's
uninitiated sees that they go i don't
want to hang out with the mean person
yeah yeah yeah um
you can't let the lie come through you
the i said earlier the
the soviet union lasted 70 years of
pretty crap
um to put it mildly do you know what led
the soviet union when it started to
actually collapse i mean there's lots of
economic factors and some other stuff
and whatever but it's when the people
the citizens actually started to laugh
at it it's like everybody knew for a
long time it was a lie and they just
kind of did it
at some point they started to laugh at
it and so when when tim said you know
it's one parent talking to another and
saying
that's ridiculous like i mean it's
stupid i guess but think about harry
potter right
so you had your literature reference i
can have my dorky literature reference
harry potter come on
harry potter three with the would the
werewolf
come on good one and what which one does
he teach right
you have this the boggarts yeah the
shape-changing boggarts the thing that
you're afraid of
is what it turns into the thing you are
the most afraid of it's going to take
away
the thing you're most worried about it's
a shape-shifting thing you don't know
what it is and what is the magic spell
that
breaks it that destroys it ridiculous
you call the thing ridiculous you
just laugh at it and that this is
actually a very useful parable
because the truth is this ideology as
horrible and dangerous as it is is also
ridiculous
it is patently ridiculous the things
that it says the things that it claims
are laughably dumb like you know what
you do
it's really really simple get your
friends if you're a parent and you're
anti-woke
and then invite an unsuspecting woke
person to your to a barbecue
and then when they're sitting there
start chanting google gobble one of us
google gobble one of us and that will
absolutely convince them to change their
minds
or run away screaming you know like in
the movie dude you do a drum circle too
yeah yeah it's more subliminal well
it's gotta you gotta be careful not to
appropriate anything then oh yeah yeah
that's right snare drums
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you